ready okay welcome everyone thank you
for coming out on a nice spring evening
I think we have a real treat for you
tonight
my name is Alison Johns I'm the
community relations manager here at
Barnes & Noble Noble Charlotte Cell
tonight we welcome author Joseph Weiland
share with us his new book Jefferson's
Vendetta the pursuit of Aaron Burr and
the judiciary
generations of Americans have revered
Thomas Jefferson is one of our greatest
leaders highly principled optimistic
untainted by vindictiveness and they've
considered Aaron Burr as his antithesis
in Jefferson's Vendetta Joseph Whelan
examines the contentious relationship
between Jefferson and his most dangerous
rival Aaron Burr and discovers a vastly
different truth extensively researched
and told in vivid detail Jefferson's
vendetta of challenges the blackened
legacy of Aaron Burr and shows the
beloved Jefferson mired in the kind of
manipulative politics that tradition has
depicted him as driving above the
Richmond times-dispatch says of this
book's take on the whole sorry episode
the title says it best this is a very
interesting situation having mr. Whelan
here in mr. Jefferson's County with his
book showing such a different view of
him and I yes I think he's very brave to
be here he's a graduate of the
University of Wyoming and the University
of Colorado Denver he's an editor and
reporter for the Associated Press and
the Casper Star Tribune in Casper
Wyoming he's also the author of
Jefferson's War Americans first war on
terror
1801 to 1809 he currently lives in North
Carolina
please welcome Joseph Whelan
good evening glad to be here in
Charlottesville beautiful city first I
guess I would like to say that I did not
set out to write a book another book
second book about Thomas Jefferson my
editor at Carroll & Graf who published
Jefferson's war marks first war and tear
became interested in the treason trial
of Aaron Burr upon reading an episode
toward the end of Jefferson's war in
which followed the later careers at some
of the principals at the Barbary war of
1801 1805 William Eden was his name and
he led famous march across the Libyan
desert to Derna
captured Derna and that led to the the
treaty that ended the war with Tripoli
and as it turned out we meetin was a
witness at the trial of Aaron Burr for
treason in Richmond 1807 and I used some
of the material from that trial in which
Burr who acted as as his own lawyer much
of the time confront confront and
William eat and on the stand and they
had quite an exchange and my editor
asked me to write a book about the about
the treason trial because not much has
been written about it in some time so I
set out to do that and I ended up
writing another book about Thomas
Jefferson because I found that his hand
was his his hand was in everything that
happened in 1807 to Aaron Burr and to
John Marshall and the judge and piece so
what I'd like to do is to start off with
a summary that I've prepared which will
bring you up to speed on what this was
all about and then
it can answer questions and talk about
other things too so I'll begin in 1807
thousands of people converged on
Richmond Virginia to see America's first
trial of the century former vice
president Aaron Burr was charged with
treason he was accused of plotting to
seize states west of the Allegheny
Mountains and also planning to lead an
expedition to conquer Spanish Texas in
Mexico but the stakes were even higher
than burrs life the very fate of the
judiciary hung in the balance as well
directing the prosecution from
Washington was Thomas Jefferson in the
middle of his second presidential term
Jefferson was a great enemy of burr and
the federal judiciary even before burrs
arrest Jefferson had declared that burrs
guilt was beyond question however the
president knew the government's treason
case against burrows week there's no
hard evidence that Byrd done anything to
seize the western states but Jefferson
believed that no matter what the outcome
he was sure to triumph because if burr
were convicted he would win outright if
burr went free he could blame the judge
and the judge was his cousin Chief
Justice John Marshall of the US Supreme
Court if Marshall let burr go free
Jefferson believed Congress might be
outraged enough to permit the removal of
troublesome federal judges like Marshall
since 1800 Jefferson had worked
relentlessly to undermine the judiciary
and destroy Aaron Burr the judiciary
Jefferson believed was a stronghold of
the rival Federalist Party in 1802 he
had repealed John Adams expansion the
Judiciary Act of the judiciary and this
was the Judiciary Act of 1801 just
passed just before Adams left office
this this particular act expanded the
judiciary greatly and created a whole
new tier of judges of US circuit judges
and expanded the Supreme Court and added
many justices of the peace but Jefferson
and his managers in the House and Senate
managed to repeal this this act and in
1804 Jefferson directed the impeachment
of the most active enforcer of the hated
Sedition Act
this was Supreme Court Associate Justice
Samuel chase the Chiefs was acquitted
and ironically at this trial Aaron Burr
was the presiding judge as as the vice
president and president and the Senate
as Byrd's trial began John Marshall was
acutely aware that he and the Judiciary
both were in grave danger and that he
must walk a tightrope to save it Aaron
Burr too was cognizant of the deadly
peril that he faced in 1800 he had been
Jefferson's running mate both
Republicans were surprised everyone
including himself by tying Jefferson for
the presidency House of Representatives
finally elected Jefferson but it took 36
ballots as runner up bird became
Jefferson's vice president that close
call convinced Jefferson that Berger
could wreck Jefferson's planned for
Virginia dynasty in the president's
house
in other words Jefferson followed by
James Madison than James Monroe which
was exactly how it played out so
Jefferson and Madison turned the
Republican press loose on burr hoping to
destroy him politically and it did then
they pushed through the twelfth
amendment changing loyd Presidents and
vice presidents were elected now
previously and in the election of 1800
the presidents were selected by electors
selected by the state legislatures in
their States each elector had two votes
of equal weight and he would cast the
first vote for his first election in the
second for his second slide
for president vice-president or whatever
but they were equal votes the twelfth
amendment changed that so that the
electors cast one vote for a ticket and
the political parties would select the
ticket with the president and vice
president
this was proved in 1804 also in 1804
Madison Jefferson kept her off the
Republican ballot that year and ran
George Clinton who's the governor in New
York is the vice president to Jefferson
and he was considered a safe vice
president because he was 70 years old so
he would not challenge the Virginia
dynasty in April 1804 Brewer and for New
York governor who knew that he was not
going to be on the ticket but Jefferson
along with the New York Republican Party
and Federalist Alexander Hamilton all
ganged up on him and he lost three
months later burr killed Hamilton in
their duel in 1805 burr returned to
private life now appeared one of the
great villains of American history James
Wilkinson Wilkinson was the general of
the army and unknown to everyone but the
Spanish he was a paid spy for Spain spy
number 13 and he had been for almost 20
years Wilkinson and burr had been
friends for 30 years since the American
Revolution
Wilkinson proposed they launched an
expedition against Spanish Texas and
Mexico filibuster it can only take place
if the United States and Spain went to
war by 1806 war appeared likely
Wilkinson and US troops faced a hostile
Spanish army near the texas-louisiana
border now rumors and reports of the
burr Wilkinson conspiracy were
everywhere Bruin 70 men however start
for Louisiana anyway to join Wilkinson
and begin their expedition
Wilkinson got cold feet he made peace
with
Spanish and he betrayed Byrd to
Jefferson and a letter claiming he had
discovered a shocking treasonous plot he
disavowed any involvement even though he
had suggested the plan in the first
place when Jefferson got the letter he
issued a nationwide alert and burr was
arrested so the stage was set for the
first trial of the century and
proceedings began in May 1807 government
prosecutors faced to the best trial
lawyers in America namely Aaron Burr and
a man named Luther Martin of Baltimore
he was he was a amazing he had an
amazing memory he could recite page
after page of statute and law and what
he liked to do during a trial and he was
arguing case was - he would have a stone
mug next to him filled with rum which he
would sip through from throughout the
day he could speak for seven hours at a
stretch amazing guy and they the
Baltimore lawyers had a nickname for him
which was a lawyer brandy bottle about
5,000 people came to Richmond to see the
trial doubling city's population as a
result the proceedings were moved to the
largest room in Virginia at that time
House of Delegates chamber in the state
capitol grand jury was convened first
jury foreman was Virginia Congressman
John Randolph who was a cousin of both
Marshall and Jefferson all three men
were descendants of William Randolph and
Mary ischium known as the Adam and Eve
of Virginia also on the grand jury were
three four three future Virginia
governors and US senators and three US
congressman so it was a it was a real
sharp a bunch of grand jurors Jefferson
and attorney general Caesar Rodney had
some and 140 prospective witnesses to
Richmond not all them were asked to
testify though Andrew Jackson for
example had been served
but when he arrived in Richmond he stood
by his friend Aaron Burr
he ended up hanging people from the
Capitol Steps about the iniquity of the
Jefferson administration the
government's star witness of course was
General of the army Wilkinson who had
betrayed birth Wilkinson was a pompous
man who loved God in uniforms and he
traveled in an entourage
he arrived in Richmond in June and the
grand jury began questioning Wilkinson
behind closed doors and questioning went
on for four days revolved around a
letter that burr had sent wilkinson and
that and which had been the trigger for
a Wilkinson alerting Jefferson to this
plot letter had been written in code the
key was a pocket dictionary that both
men possessed writing letters and code
was fairly common in those days because
postal officials snooped through all the
mail all the time this particular code
that they had set up involving this
dictionary was a series of numbers in
the first number would be the page
number and second would be the column
number and the third would be the number
of the word down that column so it was a
fairly laborious process to both write a
letter in this code and decipher it
Wilkinson had sent his translation of
the burr letter to Jefferson but it was
an unfaithful translation he had omitted
the first sentence referring to an
earlier letter that Wilkinson had sent
to Burr and Wilkinson rewrote parts of
the rest of the letter to the changes
were designed to conceal Wilkinson's
role on the kit the conspiracy in the
grand jury room however Wilkinson was
asked to furnish the jurors not only
with the translation but the original
coded letter and the key this is a smart
group of men and they quickly figured
out the system and they discovered the
Wilkinson had tampered with the
translation so then the questions flew
and Wilkinson was led to admit that
indeed he had been in contact with burro
earlier but he claimed he was only
trying to draw out burrs plot John
Randolph didn't believe him and moved to
indict Wilkinson for conspiracy to
commit treason by nine to seven vote the
indictment was rejected and this was a
actually a pretty significant vote
because the grand jury was loaded up
with
Republicans 14 Republicans and just two
Federalists on this grand jury so that
what that vote meant was that five
Republicans had sided with the two
Federalists felt that there was evidence
enough to indict Wilkinson and Wilkinson
emerged from the grand jury room on the
verge of tears and complaining bitterly
about his treatment the end of June 1807
the grand jury indicted burr and six
co-defendants for treason and violating
Spain's and neutrality vs trial was
scheduled for August
but now prosecutors didn't dare put
their star witness Wilkinson on the
witness stand because Bert and Luther
Martin would tear his testimony to
shreds his credibility was pretty well
shot the government case against burr
flimsy to begin with began to appear
unwinnable
and as burr had hoped and prosecutors
feared and finally hinged on jaw judge
John Marshall's interpretation of the
Constitution's treason clause this along
the great moments Marshalls career as
chief justice career in which he made
the judiciary the equal the executive
and legislative branches Marshall was
chief justice for 34 years 1801 until
his death in 1835 and he in fact no one
has served that long since as chief
justice he still holds the record
Marshall ruled that that for there to be
treason there must be an overt act of
war against the United States witnessed
by two people
the exact language of article 3 section
3 of the Constitution so he interpreted
it strictly down the line now in other
countries a person might hang for merely
wishing the death of his nation's leader
but in the United States that person
would have to act on the wish in the
presence of two witnesses this was
deliberately written into the
Constitution at the insistence of
Benjamin Franklin who did not want to
see the abuses that had been that had
transpired in England and other
countries England especially they said
the valleys were filled with bullet
graves because of the persecution of
people who were viewed as dissenters but
it really hadn't done anything to
overthrow the the royal government or
anything he didn't want that to happen
in the United States so that's why it
was written that way marshals strict
constitutional interpretation was the
last word on treason law until World War
two so who was Aaron Burr he's one of
the most intriguing figures in American
history my research I found that he's
still usually depicted much as the
Republican press portrayed him in the
early 1800s during their smear campaign
against him in other words as a mountain
of depravity however he came from a very
distinguished family his father was the
second president of the College in New
Jersey Princeton University quite famous
his grandfather was Jonathan Edwards who
was a famed evangelist from New England
who wrote sinners in the hands of an
angry god which is still on a lot of
college English anthologies today when
Burr was - his father and mother died
and of smallpox
and then his grandparents Jonathan
Edwards and his wife came down from
Massachusetts to the Rays burner and his
sister who was Sarah was four years old
I believe and they got sick Jonathan
Edwards took over Aaron Burr seniors
position as president of college in New
Jersey but within a year he was dead and
so was his wife
so in in one year hold Jenner two
generations of bers family had been
wiped out by either smallpox or cholera
so Berners sister were raised by an
uncle Timothy Edwards who's a reverend
in western Massachusetts he bur was
applied for admission to college in New
Jersey when he was 11 years old he was a
very precocious boy and he would have
been admitted except he was he was small
even for his age you just looked tiny
and so they said you would have he would
have to wait a couple years we studied
very hard he was admitted when he was 13
and he graduated in three years at the
age of 16 his uncle thought that he
would become a minister too but after a
year study became apparent he was not
interested in that he's more interested
in going into the law then the
Revolutionary War broke out in 1775 he
went into the Continental Army as an
officer and he participated in the
campaign against Quebec he was at the
Battle of Monmouth courthouse he was
also a training officer at Valley Forge
during that terrible winter his his unit
was so well trained that Washington sent
him to train a unit that had
disciplinary problems he got out in 1779
and finished his legal education
and got married he was an early
abolitionist superb lawyer he was what
you would call I suppose a proto
feminist who raised his daughter
Theodosius as people raised their sons
back in those days and he kept a
portrait of Mary Wollstonecraft until
the end of his life later years it
became a surrogate parent to several
children but he was certainly flawed
he had a politician's failing of telling
people what he what he thought they
wanted to hear he chose his friends
badly in this expedition that he planned
was a very poorly plan Andrew Jackson
noted that burr was as far from being a
fool as anyone he knew except when it
came to the friends that he made and
trusted why hasn't his reputation
improved with time there are some good
reasons for that first winners write the
history in this case was Thomas
Jefferson and Madison Jefferson was
known to go back and change his journal
entries and letters need be
second burr never believed in responding
to slander he had this thing called a
Chesterfield in approach to social
intercourse he believed that you need to
be a gentleman that you didn't respond
things were untrue said against you and
the people would find the truth and by
the time he discovered he was completely
wrong on that it was too late
although he did try to he did start a
newspaper to compete with fit papers at
Madison and Jefferson were supporting
smear but the editor was a real
gentleman - it was his name was Peter
Irving he was Washington Irving's
brother
another reason that burrs reputation
suffered is that his most important
papers were lost at sea along with his
daughter Theodosian and early 1813 so
there hasn't been much to refute things
that were said against him by other
people down through the years and what
of Thomas Jefferson's behavior in 1807
conducted the greatest dragnet for
government witnesses that would be seen
till the days following nine-one-one he
declared burrs guilt beyond question
before he was even arrested he planned
to bring down John Marshall if borough
were acquitted in fact after the treason
trial which Aaron Burr was acquitted of
all charges Jefferson sent his four
managers in Congress legislation to
allow Congress and or the the executive
to to fire judges they if they had a
two-thirds majority fortunately that
went nowhere the Congress at that time
it was preoccupied with problems with
Great Britain which had attacked our
shipping off jigna coast and attacked a
US frigate the Chesapeake in fact during
the middle of the Aaron Burr trial off
the Virginia caped 1807 was the nadir of
Jefferson's presidency he was having
trouble with James Monroe he was the
minister to Great Britain at that time
and he had he had signed a treaty with
Great Britain which included no no
provision at all for for England to stop
impressing us seamen was the major issue
between the countries
he was upset with him over that and
Monroe wanted to come back to the United
States and run for president in 1808 and
Jefferson had made it clear that Madison
was going to be the next
atención Monroe had to wait his turn
this was all happening as during the
burr manhunt as was this controversy
between two of Jeff Jefferson's two son
and laws who were happened to both be
congressman from Virginia and they were
feuding publicly over which of them
Jefferson favored over the other so he
was having a rough time of it at that
point after the attack on the Chesapeake
Jefferson and Madison decided instead of
going to war they impose the embargo
which stopped all trade with Europe and
that was a failure so it was a bad year
for Jefferson any questions at this
point
yes oh that's that's interesting the the
the act of the supposed act of treason
occurred allegedly on an island in the
Ohio River called Blennerhassett Island
and it was actually as part of West
Virginia today but then was part of
Virginia so they were just the
government felt it was justified and
basing its charge against him there
another reason probably was that
Jefferson wanted the trial close at hand
so that he could send instructions down
every other day to the US attorney
George hey who is prosecuting the case
and he did and hey sent daily reports
from Richmond to Washington they've
couriers going back and forth and I
think I suspect a third reason might
have been to because Jefferson and
Madison knew that John Marshall would
have to preside over this case the way
things were set up then the Supreme
Court in those days the judges each had
a circuit that he was responsible for
and he would actually ride the circuit
on his horse and Marshalls circuit was
Virginia and the Carroll
- so he would go out and he would sit on
cases with the US District Judge in
Richmond Raleigh Charleston did that all
the time so Jefferson and Madison knew
you would he would be there in Richmond
and I think it might have it was an
opportunity that Jefferson saw to bring
down Marshall at that point he jeff
Jefferson had believed since it's the
late 1790s that the judiciary had too
much power it had too much potential to
get even more power and initially he'd
believed that impeachment was the way to
go and he had orchestrated the
impeachment of two federal judges
Samuel chase and then before him a
federal judge from New England who
actually was about half out of his mind
and should have resigned from the bench
and he not only was impeached he was
convicted and removed it was really a
sad case and Congress but after chase
was acquitted Jefferson decided that
impeachment was not a good tool and that
the way to go was to get Congress to
pass either legislation or a
constitutional amendment to allow the
removal the judges and Jefferson
believed as as a matter of principle
with him that the judiciary should not
be the equal of the executive and
legislative branches the and and back
then when the country was still young
and there were no precedents on how to
proceed with this I mean today we take
it for granted three branches of
government equal but he believed that
the judiciary should not should not be
equal it kind of ran off on that
in other questions yes sir
was it fair to say that your book
suggests a Jefferson's sponsorship of
the twelfth Amendment of the
Constitution diluted the original
concept of American democracy no not at
all
I think basically it it was probably a
good thing because it simplified the
selection of the President and
vice-president made it made it possible
for political parties to it made it
possible for political parties can to
control more of the process and they had
before previously you had a situation in
1796 for example John Adams the
Federalists got the most votes became
president and the number 2 person was a
Republican Thomas Jefferson so you had
two people of opposite parties serving
together and at cross-purposes - yeah
yeah it was pretty much
yes it was I'm not sure that the motive
was entirely pure though the I think it
was also aimed at keeping BER off the
ballot in 1804 by some chance he was
able to marshals it there's the great
fear that Burwood marshal support from
discontented Republicans and the
Federalists who were out of power and
somehow pull them together into a
coalition and become elected so that was
probably the prime motive at the time
turned out to be a good thing that
really was quite taken aback all I
learned about Jefferson even if only
part of that was true
really depicted him as a very
manipulative right it's just that it was
just so kind of shocking unfortunately
I'm not a native Virginian I can claim
to angry Jack's still I just wonder if
you could kind of of the three man
Hamilton Jefferson and burr if you could
just give a couple of lines of
assessment of those sure I would say
Hamilton Jefferson and Madison founded
the the modern political system they
founded partisan politics they were the
fathers of partisan politics and that
happened in the early 1790s and of
course Hamilton found himself on the
opposite side of the divide with the
Jefferson and Madison and so the the
infighting early on through the election
1800 was it was really brutal as I'm
sure you've read the the election 1800
puts anything we've probably seen in our
lifetime in the shade as far as just
malice now as far as burr burr is not
really
at the time the 1800 election what you
would call a national figure at all he
was put on the ballot by Jefferson
Jefferson wanted him to run as his
running mate and the reason was because
Byrd was able to deliver New York State
to the Republican Party and he did it by
setting up the probably what was the
first political machine in New York City
using what then was called the Society
of st. Tammany was they yeah they they
operated out of Tammany Hall it was not
the Tammany Hall they built the Tammany
Hall Iran but indeed this is exactly how
they operated and they set up a card
filing system they had every every voter
on a card how much money they could give
how much time how they were gonna vote
and or just to organize it superbly
elected the slate of candidates from New
York City
and they went to the legislature and
that tipped the balance for the
Republicans suit so anyway he was he was
Jefferson Madison and Albert Gallatin
had asked her to do this early and 1800
to deliver New York State and he did it
in the election of April of 1804 said
the same there 1800 he set it up one New
York City the New York Assembly was
Republican they were they were going to
deliver the electoral votes but to
ensure that they stayed Republican they
wanted a New Yorker to run with
Jefferson so they asked George Clinton
the governor and he was well known
outside in New York very well known and
Clinton said agreed that he that he
would but he said he wanted to resign
whenever he felt like it so they decided
that that wasn't a good proposition so
he looked at the other not the other big
political power center in the
which was the Livingston family but
decided that Livingston wasn't robert
Livingston what didn't have the name
recognition outside of New York sober
was the third selection and he turned
him down flat because he wasn't
interested in being vice-president at
all and they had to talk him into it so
that's how he became a national figure
was because he delivered New York State
and very reluctantly became the vice
presidential candidate
a very difficult time without a happy
yes immediately the Republican press was
turned loose on him and they brought up
all sorts of thing he was just a moral
monster and the the press had a lot more
leeway and used it in the in those days
to slander people they their cooperation
and attribution were pretty poor and
they would just say things and they did
and in fact in the late 1790s now
Madison and Jefferson did the same thing
to George Washington and Alexander
Hamilton smeared them and the paid
newspapers to do it and Washington was
completely exasperated with Jefferson at
that point but I think the way to look
at Thomas Jefferson though his he was a
user ruthless political operative any he
was a winner he won all the time except
in 1796 won 1800 and he got his dynasty
for good or bad his methods worked and
he got his Virginia dynasty for 24 years
there's one person in this whole fair
was I guess you would call a victim and
his name was Harmon Blennerhassett and
he owned the island which this whole
disastrous expedition was staged from
the island in the Ohio River it's just
off of Parkersburg West Virginia and
it's a part of the West Virginia State
Historical parks system really an
interesting place to go to the
Blennerhassett that was an emigrate from
Ireland he'd inherited some money but
then he had made the mistake of marrying
his niece and this was really frowned
upon and Catholic Ireland at that time
so they left and he was a lawyer but he
had inherited this money and he bought
this land on Blennerhassett Island and
built a mansion there and brought in
cattle and yeah and raising cattle and
he was a scholar he had a fabulous
library and he he was kind of a amateur
chemist and studied literature in
languages and he played musical
instruments
well burr in 1805 was scouting out what
he was going to do after he was after he
was vice president he used roon in
politics he had lost the New York
governor's race he was off the vice
presidential ticket off the ticket with
Jefferson he had shot Hamilton and was
wanted for murder in New Jersey so he
didn't feel like he could go back to New
York City and practice law again he
thought he'd be arrested and spirited in
New Jersey and hanged for killing
Hamilton in a duel so he teamed up with
Wilkinson and
he went he bought a houseboat in
Pittsburgh for one hundred and thirty
three dollars and sailed down the Ohio
River scouting things out seeing where
he could watch this expedition from
there were supporters whatever so he
landed at Blennerhassett Island and he
was a very charming man he made friends
with Harmon Blennerhassett and his wife
and persuaded them to join in so when
this whole thing collapsed in the early
1800s a rested harmon was charged with
treason as well as bur he was one of the
other six co-defendants and as a result
of this even though he was he was never
convicted of anything
he lost the island he lost his mansion
he lost all of his property everything
he ended up going back to Great Britain
and I think died number years later just
poverty-stricken on one of the Channel
Islands between in the English Channel
so if there was a victim it was him he
was you really believed in burr and he
believed the promises that he would be
paid back and he never was after this
bird went to Europe for four years and
he lived a long time after this he lived
until he was 80 years old 1836 he was
disgraced run creditors were after him
but so he got got on a ship and he went
to Europe 1808 and he stayed for four
years and he nearly starved to death -
he tried to raise money various means he
tried to enlist support for his schemes
one was to for Great Britain to help him
capture a Cuba take Cuba over from Spain
but nothing worked he ended up living in
a garret in Paris unheated in the winter
half frozen to death starving
translating books from English into
French for money for food money and one
of the books he was translating he
realized that slandered him but he
needed the money so bad that he went
ahead and translated him so he came back
to the United States in 1812 and landed
in fact on the very day that Unites
States declared war on Great Britain and
his daughter had Theodosia had married
man in South Carolina named Joseph
Alston he was Kim Hughes the governor at
that point in 1812 and they had a they
had a son his name was Aaron Burr Alston
and Aaron Burr thought the world to him
they did too well at soon after he
returned the United States the boy died
he was just 11 and it was a real
shattering event in the family and
Theodosius health just crumbled under
this under the strain of this and she
they feared for her life her husband
dead and so he and burr arranged to have
her get on a ship and sail to New York
to join her father thinking the the
bracing northern air would would help
and all these and she was raised in New
York too
but less than a week after the ship left
South Carolina that vanished at sea and
was never seen again
and on that ship were the her father's
most important papers which he had left
with her when he went to Europe and that
she was bringing to him and they just
disappeared the thinking was that there
was a British blockade or off the coast
that reported a gale hitting Cape
Hatteras about that time
then all these wild stories circulated
and books were written novels magazine
stories about what happened in
Theodosian 1 there are two other
versions one was that some of the crew
members of the ship were in fact pirates
and had mutinied overwhelmed the the
captain and crew taken over the ship
made everybody walked the plank and then
had taken the ship and sailed away with
it and although everything on the the
other story which was kind of intriguing
was that the Wreckers of the Outer Banks
in North Carolina they were called
wreckers there were basically land
pirates who would by using falsi lights
and signals would lure ships aground on
the Outer Banks and then they would roll
out and kill everybody and and strip the
ships of all the goods this story was
given more credence when late I was
after mid-century the 19th century this
elderly woman was dying in a cottage
Nags Head North Carolina
doctor was sent for and he came out and
he noticed in this humble cottage a
portrait of a woman a young woman dark
hair white skin dark eyes or a black
dress and she said that her husband had
found that portrait and a trunk of fine
clothing on the ship that supposedly had
was found empty just floating off the
coast there and they had rowed out
there's no one on the ship so they had
taken the what was on the ship and kept
it for years there was conjecture that
that portrait was Theodosia fedosya
brewer Alston but and and the doctor
obtained that portrait and the clothes
of the trunk of clothing which also was
found in the wall
cabin which included a black fail on a
black dress very nice material but the
the Austin family never really was able
to claim that that portrait was
Theodosius never proved one or the other
it's probably probably was not there's a
lot written about that it's a green
mystery the early 19th century questions
yes introducing Dali painting Todd to
James Madison in 1793 yeah yes they did
yeah that was that was interesting that
did happen burr was a u.s. senator from
New York State at that point and had
arrived in Philadelphia he was staying
at a boarding house it happened to be
run by Dolly Todd's mother and he became
good friends with her and about that
time Dolly arrived at the boarding house
though she was a new widow she had a
baby and Burr became great friends with
her in fact such close friends that in
her will she she that she wrote about
that time she said that if anything
happened to her she wanted her to take
care of her baby
so Burr was looking out after and he
said he knew this bachelor friend of his
that he had gone to college with that I
like to come over for dinner and it was
James Madison and he so he introduced
them and they were married soon after
that they were college classmates at
that time
exactly did he introduce them building
what place oh it was that it was at that
boarding house they mad at James Madison
was invited over for dinner at the
boarding house and that's how he met
dolly
yeah and they took it from there did she
attempt to defend her years are trying
to befriend heaven well when Brewers in
Europe
his daughter Theodosius trying
everything to get see the problem was
the embassies in England US embassies in
England and Paris doing everything make
sure the bird did not get back to the
United States they were giving him a
hard time and so Theodosius aware of
this and she was trying to pull every
string that she could and that was one
of the things that she did was to
contact Dolly Madison wrote her a letter
and asked her if there's anything she
could do for her father and Dolly wrote
a letter back saying she really
regretted it but there really wasn't
anything she could do but then shortly
after that Burr was granted got his
papers and he came over here so there's
speculation that perhaps she did use her
influence yes I understand what you said
Jefferson was about this positivity
how do you assess Madison's party this
and therefore whose character in
relationship to this association with
Jefferson and this vendetta against
Madison's role is always very shadowy
throughout but he was from what I can
understand from my readings Edison was
the one who got things done Jefferson
was kind of the political theorists
Madison was the practical man they
worked together as a team and it's hard
to pin down exactly who did what when
because they were very careful not to
believe records of things that they did
the way that you determined their role
was to look at the outcome now of common
I mean when Jefferson was president and
Madison Secretary of State Congress did
everything that they wanted them to do
they controlled Congress absolutely and
Madison actually was probably the better
politician than Jefferson Jefferson more
of a theorist Madison the practical
Politico but I'd like to see more
written about James Madison he was an
excellent politician he was he wrote
much of the Constitution he had a huge
role in founding a this country he did
not have a good presidency he was
probably a better working as part of a
group or as in tandem with another
strong person kind of my take on him
another interesting thing I'll just
briefly mention if it is the Hamilton
burr animosity and where did that begin
from what I can determine now it began
in 1791 1792 and burr was appointed by
the New York State Assembly to the US
Senate he replaced Philip Schuyler
Philip Schuyler was Alexander Hamilton's
father-in-law and that's where their
rivalry began right there
Hamilton acquired the habit that of
writing letters making remarks about
burr it went on for 12 years
they almost dueled once in 1799 and when
Hamilton was killed John Adams remarked
that basically that you know he had a
coming it was about time this had been
going on for more than 10 years he was
not surprised
or did he mourn Hamilton
it's very interesting about the founding
of the country and the relationship
between Hamilton and Washington which
I've it I can do nothing about Clement
Attlee and then hue all the fighting
between Washington and Jefferson really
surprised me how much bitterness and
stuff going on all the time between
these two men who we thought I miss
Virginia and missing founders it really
is it's really worth reading and I look
forward to reading this and it's
certainly the he likes him
and that comes through in the book but
just the history is to picture this it's
just best I think it's interesting that
people are four years have viewed these
men as icons you know kind of marble
statue men basically and now we're
starting to see more the human side of
what they really like and which I think
makes him even more remarkable because
you see them as human beings who complex
these amazing things that lasted till
today they weren't gods or anything they
weren't they were extraordinary men
when you look at all that went on in
1800 it's easier to look at what goes on
today and have faith that the country is
going to go forward when sometimes it
just seems like - the bitterness